welcome back it's time for drew's news
your swish swash of the good news
mouthwash and with me at the desk
there's no man more minty fresh rossy
ross matthew
hi hi everybody
all right first step ross this story
just freaked me out are you ready for it
yes all right
ross i'm gonna put all of us on the spot
we need to talk about sheets how often
do you wash yours i go about
a week to 10 days all right well
everybody buckle up what
hold on to your headboard matthews
because
we have the answer from a doctor
cosmopolitan reports
dermatologists say that you should be
washing your sheets once a week how many
people
uh raise your hands wash your sheets
once a week ish yeah yeah yeah
this one is where it gets dark
you're supposed to wash your i'm like
drooling i'm so anxious
you're supposed to wash your pillowcases
every day what
oh no you think get ready
we shed 30 to 40 000 skin cells a day
many of them in the bed and you know who
loves to chow down on skin cells no i
don't want to know that's mine
and your mattress becomes a bed buffet
i mean i literally i think i'm literally
getting like itchy like allergic
reactions telling this story
is it
i'm not kidding i know it's like i this
isn't like theatrics i understand i am i
like need a better drill the dust mites
disgusting it's something i don't want
to think about i know they exist but i
don't want to acknowledge them like
bills or calories i don't want to know
about you dust mites
gross
okay ross your story all right next
story pure wow reports painting your
bathroom a certain color can increase
your home's value by 5
dollars what what yes uh-huh so everyone
guess in your mind what color it is
think about it five thousand dollars
just by painting a room yes and the
color is pale sky blue
yeah
zillow did an analysis and people were
willing to spend 1.5
more on a home if the bathroom was pale
sky blue yeah that's a crazy fact is are
any of your bathrooms this color no
me either what about your bedrooms they
say dark moody colors increase the value
of your house too for a moody bedroom
but for kitchens stay away from mint
green they say the kitchen that is the
kitchen kiss of death it can devalue
your home by two thousand dollars
i know well i'm really surprised to hear
about the mint green kitchens because in
a lot of decor magazines you see a lot
of green kitchens i guess but i guess
you have to when you're selling a house
think about what the customer wants you
know what i mean when you so if you're
blue bathrooms not green kitchens and
dark bedrooms
what's that all about you know what
that's about girl you know what that's
about
i forgot what that's about
um
well people might hate mint green
kitchens but i know one mint that we can
all get behind a thin mint oh my god i
love a thin mint cookie by the way while
i've calmed my itch situation down i've
also been smelling something incredible
and it's this it's girl scout cookie
season ross oh thank god you know what i
call thin mints what double chin mints
because i will go to town on a finment
oh my god i love that so much i'm so
glad so i could just hear that well
guess what everybody it's time for food
news so this just in the girl scouts
just got a new cookie cnn reveals that
the newest star in the lineup is the
adventure full cookie well this cookie
is inspired by the brownies and it has
salted caramel and is a brownie so the
brownies got a brownie let's try it you
had me add salted caramel you ready
mm-hmm
mm-hmm
oh
my
god
yeah
yeah right i can't even there's i'll go
away from them
oh my god i'm not coming who who likes
dropout cookies
[Applause]
okay
i planned all day for that cooking
i really adjusted my lunch the whole
thing so i could have that cookie
and that was good that's the best date
i've been on a long time i'll tell you
that is so phenomenal that i feel bad
eating it in front of everybody because
all i want them to have is the
experience i just had i know but um you
can go to
girlscouts.org and buy your cookies and
support the girl scouts today and order
this one this one is so delish
don't mess around
get the adventure falls this is um this
might be my new favorite yum wait until
you try these i wish god darn it why
don't we have more of them all right
we'll be right back to play pop quiz
[Music]